hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled will we have a vaccine
for covid19
five reasons for optimism this webinar
is part of an ongoing coronavirus
virtual webinar series i'm susie valdez
and
of labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
so let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you'd
like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process for obtaining
those credits without further ado i now
present today's
speaker dr rob kozak clinical
microbiologist
sunny brook health sciences center
associate professor the department of
laboratory medicine
and pathobiology at university of
toronto
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr kozak you may now begin your
presentation welcome sir
thank you so much dr valdez for the uh
kind introduction and
um thank you to my uh uh online audience
uh everyone for for coming it's a
pleasure to be able to
talk to you today a little bit about uh
vaccines
and i hope by the end of this you'll uh
leave with the same optimism that uh
that i have um so just in general today
we're gonna talk about several of the
vaccine candidates
um that are that are in current
development right now
as well i'm going to talk a little bit
about some of the lessons that i think
we can
learn from sars and mers there's going
to be a few considerations which i think
can also be
not just challenges but opportunities
for the scientific community
moving forward and of course i'll leave
you with my my five reasons for optimism
at the end
i'd just also like to say that i have no
relevant conflicts of interest
or financial disclosures so i don't
think anyone would agree that we really
really do need a vaccine for uh for
covet 19. this is a um
a sign sent from a a colleague of mine
which is a quite humorous but also kind
of highlights that
even though we have a lot of good public
health measures in place such as social
distancing
uh and the use of masks and that has
been really really useful in certain
areas
at flattening the curve uh in order to
uh
get things back to some sort of normal
we are going to need to uh
have her immunity within the uh the
general population and that will
likely require a a vaccine
so if you're a a real vaccine if you're
really passionate about vaccines like i
am you can
you can actually follow on the the new
york times has a real-time vaccine
tracker although
uh the pace of vaccine research i don't
know the uh how useful real-time tracker
truly is
but i think it's interesting because it
really highlights that there are quite a
number of different vaccines that you
can see there in various stages so
there's
just over 100 in in the the pre-clinical
stage
uh and then there's a handful that are
in uh phase one and phase two
two that are currently uh in in phase
three and
uh to date we don't have any that are uh
that are approved
um and this isn't surprising uh because
if you think about all the steps that
that really take to get uh
you know vaccine from from concept all
the way to uh uh to putting it into the
um
uh into into people to convert
protection it's quite a long road and
usually this is a process
that can take uh potentially decades to
it to accomplish
so even after the clinical things after
you've done all the scientific work
which we'll
talk about in a moment there are a
number of other uh
steps that are that are really um
important but are often
not really considered uh you know by
frontline researchers
so first off there's the whole good
manufacturing process so you may have an
excellent vaccine but you have to be
able to manufacture it
properly and and under very stringent
conditions if you're going to then use
it for uh
for clinical trials of course there are
the different phases of clinical trials
which i'll go into in just a moment
but assuming that your vaccine makes it
all the way through and is successful in
each of the different phases
at that point you're you're still not
home free because
there uh there is the requirement for
for licensure and approval by the
various regulatory
bodies um and of course uh something
that often is not considered by
a lot of researchers is uh the need for
uh being able to scale up production so
especially for something that's a
pandemic you're going to need to create
likely billions of doses of this so
uh the production can be a bit of a
bottleneck then even if you do have the
production in place
there is the uh there's also the rate
limiting stuff of administration
so it's not like you can just
automatically give out the vaccine to
billions of people
you have to uh figure out how to how to
administer it uh how to distribute it
and then uh with every vaccine it takes
time for
uh following the the uh the vaccination
in order
to uh to generate uh immunity so it's a
if we're able to get one within 18
months that will be uh at
just a a record pace um but you can see
now why it often takes quite
quite a long time and if we go back
even just to the pre-clinical uh uh side
of vaccine development which is probably
what a lot of people think about when
you think about uh research being done
in the lab
there are some things that you that uh
that you need there there are some
challenges to overcome so first off uh
you need to select a
an antigen um and then you also need a
candidate vaccine so you need a
a vector or some sort of some sort of
system that you can use to deliver that
vaccine into uh
into either animals and then later on
into into people
um you also need the pathogen so you
need to have the virus isolated
uh in order to do the uh the next step
which is the uh the animal challenge
models
so you also need a good animal model of
the of the disease in order to uh
properly evaluate whether or not a um a
vaccine is efficacious
and probably one of the more the most
critical things you need the funding and
uh uh
and resources in order to support this
is there long studies and and uh and
money is certainly uh
certainly required and once you get
through all this that's when you can
actually move into the uh
the clinical trials so probably a lot of
people in the audience are familiar with
uh the different phase of clinical
trials but i'll just give a really quick
overview of what we mean by each of them
just so that we're all on the same page
so when we talk about phase one clinical
trials
these are the trials where you have a
small generally a small number of
individuals
who are given the vaccine and what
you're really looking for here is
the the safety profile and identifying
the uh the
the optimal dosage of your of your
vaccine candidate
if you're successful here you then move
on to the uh the second
phase phase two and these are the larger
trials that uh are used to generate
uh immunogenicity they often involve a
diverse group
or diverse segments of the population in
order to see that the immunogenicity is
is is constant in all groups so it might
include the elderly or it might include
children depending on your your vaccine
and then if you're successful there you
move on to the
uh the next phase which is um the phase
three
this is the large-scale trial that
evaluates the efficacy of the vaccine
so the good news is that often these
phases can be combined so you could have
for example a phase one two or or
as we'll see in a moment some of them
are in phase two three
um so that can sometimes save time but
vaccines can really fail at any stage
and not just because they may fail for
scientific reasons such as they
they really fail to generate
immunogenicity a sufficient immune
response or medical reasons like they
have too many adverse
effects but often uh factors that are
not that
can cause it to fail that we often don't
consider so things like uh
you may not have be able to enroll
enough people in order to achieve uh
sufficient power to evaluate your
your vaccine or uh you may run out of uh
support and funding uh in order to move
next phase which is actually what we saw
with the um
uh some of the vaccine trials for for
sars cov1
uh back in 2000 and uh 2004 2005
where uh they a number of vaccines made
into phase one trial
and then uh didn't didn't progress
further from there
so one of the other things i said we
need uh in the pre-clinical work is
obviously the uh the virus so
uh there have been a number of groups
have isolated the virus all around the
world and this is excellent because it's
now available to
uh to researchers everywhere for uh for
performing these studies so i'm sure
everybody is a is well familiar by this
point
in the uh in the conference uh what um
uh what the virus is but again just so
we're all on the same page so i'm when
i'm talking about uh i'm talking about
sarsko v2 which is the
ideological agent of the disease 19
uh it is a coronavirus part of the beta
coronavirus genus
like other coronavirus is a positive
sense single strand rna genome
it's enveloped like stars one it uses
the the ace2 receptor
um and one of the critical um proteins
that i'm going to talk a lot about today
is the
the spike glycoprotein which you can see
the picture in the corner the
the yellow proteins that are all around
the edge of the virus or
they can also be seen in the electron
micrograph just at the bottom of the
page
um so these these proteins are are
what's used by the
the virus to bind to the h2 receptor and
enter the cell
uh they also are the reason that the the
virus got its name
corona meaning crown because these uh uh
these these proteins give it sort of a
crown like on the electron micrograph
so that's good we have access to the
virus we also have
a number of animal models which as i
said is very important for a lot of the
pre-clinical work
we were fortunate that a lot of the
knowledge that we had from sars and mers
we can kind of apply to uh
kobit 19 which i think really sort of
expedited the
process and really made development uh
of animal models go a lot faster
so from stars and mers we knew that uh
non-human primates and ferrets were both
uh excellent models for um uh for
performing various uh
uh pathology studies and also for
vaccines and therapeutics
um the ace ii transgenic mice we know
was um uh
was used for uh for sars and since then
we've also uh known
we've also determined that uh syrian
hamsters are are also another
uh animal model for uh for covet 19 and
they're also able to mimic transmission
as do as do ferrets so each of these
models they have their advantages and
disadvantages
obviously smaller models such as mice
and ferrets and hamsters are easier to
cage and uh
and are a little bit less costly than
the non-human primates
but non-human primates are advantageous
because they are more closely resemble
uh uh what we see in in humans
um and basically with a lot of the the
development of animal models
uh involves determining the best way to
uh uh
to challenge the the animal to mimic as
close to possible
what we see the disease we see in humans
so for this what we do is an intranasal
challenge with the uh
with the virus and uh there is value to
determining what is the optimal dose
and then following the uh the intranasal
challenge
uh what you do is you basically you
monitor these animals for viremia you
look for viral shedding and nasal swabs
and you do um uh evaluation clinical
scoring to look for
uh look for disease and at various time
points you may euthanize the animal in
order to look at
the viral burden and organs as well as a
histopathology
ideally what you're hoping for when
you're when you have an animal model is
you want a lethal model and
why we want that is because it's a lot
easier to see whether you're vaccine or
if you were if you were
testing a therapy um whether or not it's
it's really having
an effect if you if you have a lethal
model and and your vaccine prevents uh
prevents
animal death that is advantageous
unfortunately
the um models that that people have
developed so far
are not are not uniformly lethal some of
them some
some of the animal models there there is
a point where the animals some of the
animals will
will succumb to the illness they're not
usually lethal which adds challenges
when we're doing vaccine studies
so recently uh there was a a paper
published in science which was uh
uh excellent it's really highlighted
that non-human primates are a really
really good
model of copit19 and they really mimic
what we see
uh in humans so i've just highlighted a
couple of key uh
figures from from the paper i encourage
you all to take a look at it
um this this group actually took both
young
and uh and aged non-human primates and
uh
gay uh infected them with them with
sarso v2 and actually showed that the
the disease phenotype is similar to what
we see in humans so uh generally we see
in humans uh older individuals we see a
much more severe disease with a higher
viral load
and we see the same here so the as you
can see in those figures the uh the
black bar represents the um
uh the aged animals where which is hot
and you see higher viral loads
um and more uh dissemination into the
organs than you do
in the in the younger uh the younger
animals
and what was also interesting is they
they actually did a head-to-head
comparison
of both sarsko v2 uh sars one
and mers so they did a a full-on uh
pathology study
uh to compare what uh to compare the
disease course
um in all these uh using all these
different viruses
in these uh non-human primates and
really demonstrated that
uh the non-human primate really
represents uh
is an excellent model of what we see uh
what we see going forward
uh in in in human disease and so this is
very encouraging because as i said
non-human primates are really our gold
standard model for
uh for looking at vaccine efficacy um
and so having one that uh that
accurately represents the disease that
we see with covet 19 is is very
important
okay so what have we learned from stars
and merge that can potentially help us
get a a vaccine sooner with uh with with
covet 19.
um so what we saw with both sars and
mers is that there there were actually a
whole range of different uh vaccine
candidates and
and types of vaccines that were
investigated there was no real one that
sort of stood out saying oh this is the
exact type of uh
vector the exact type of vaccine that
works and nothing else does
so this is encouraging it means that
there's lots of different options on the
table
and the different vaccine types that
were examined kind of they they kind of
run the spectrum so
on one end you've kind of got your
you've got your live attenuated and then
your inactivated virus
so these are using the actual virus and
either uh deleting part of it or or
inactivating it through through chemical
treatments
and these have their advantages that
they are often what is
closer to uh uh to natural infection in
the case of live attenuated
and they're easier to uh um they're
quite easy to develop you can develop
them quickly
uh using an inactivated vaccine but both
of them have safety concerns
now if you move further down the
spectrum into using a um
a viral vector so another virus where
you you get it to exp
uh to express the um one of the antigens
from either sars or mers
these are a little safer and they do
generate a good immune response
but they may not work in all segments of
the population so people that are
are immunocompromised may not be able to
tolerate them and also
like any uh live viral vector there are
difficulties in in production
the ones that are probably the easiest
to produce are the the subunit vaccine
so a protein based vaccine or or a dna
vaccine
these were shown to be easy to produce
they obviously have very safe
very favorable safety profiles the
problem is that they may not always be
immunogenic
um you have to you have to determine
what the ideation
and so result they may uh they may have
uh the requirement for multiple doses
but generally what we take from this is
that all forms of
all the different types of vaccines have
shown varying degrees of efficacy and
and were investigated for sars immersed
so there's
lots of options on the table and i
should also state for
uh just in case you're not here with uh
you know vaccine studies
generally when we're looking at vaccine
efficacy there's really kind of three
things that we're uh that we're kind of
focused on so we want to make sure that
the vaccine will uh
generate virus-specific antibodies and
and t cells and a high titer of
antibodies
we also want to make sure those
antibodies are are neutralizing because
although it hasn't been determined all
the correlates of protection
uh for uh cyroscopy ii uh generally
speaking neutralizing antibodies are
associated with protection in many viral
illnesses
and of course probably the most
important thing we want to make sure the
the animals that are vaccinated survive
and if we don't have a um a lethal model
of infection
we at least want to see that the the
vaccinated animals have a more moderate
disease which can mean
lower viral burdens less clinical
symptoms we want to see that they're
doing better
than the ones than the animals that uh
that get the sham vaccine
so now in terms of selecting antigens
again we can we can
learn a lot from what we saw with the
with sars and mers and this this has
been applied i think by a lot of
uh a lot of the the vaccines for covet
19 rather than testing out
and trying all the different uh proteins
that are present in um
uh in the virus the spike protein which
encodes that glycoprotein that i showed
you a few slides ago that sort of coats
the outside of the virus
this is really a good choice for an
antigen um
so the the spike protein or what i would
just refer to as the s antigen
um it's the one that that binds to the
the host receptor and allows the virus
to get in so obviously
developing antibodies against this will
help uh
neutralize the virus from being able to
um
uh to enter the uh the cell and there
were a number of studies that were done
with uh with sars that showed if you
took antibodies
uh against the sars protein from
survivors and passively transferred them
into
small animal models you also conferred
uh conferred protection
both a really really elegant study was
actually this
uh one done uh uh in pnas in in 2004
and so what this group did this this
table's a little bit busy so i'll just
walk you through
it what basically they did is they took
um para influenza virus
and through um a little bit of genetic
engineering
got the peri-influenza virus to express
various proteins from sars so either the
s protein
or the e protein or the uh the nucleic
acid protein
and then they use these to uh to
vaccinate um
uh to vaccinate animals and looked at
whether the
uh these uh these vaccines convert
protection so in the very last column
what you can see where it says percent
with
detectable sars cove in the in the lungs
the only ones where there was no
detectable virus
was in the the mice that had received
the um
vaccines containing the the s protein so
none of the other uh none of the other
proteins
uh certain none of the other vaccines
expressed the other proteins really
induce protective immunity
so this really shows us that the s
antigen is probably the
the best bang for our buck and we also
see similar studies uh
from what's been shown with uh with mers
so this is from a recent
a couple of recent studies where uh
there was a group that was studying the
dna vaccine that expresses the s gene
from
so again the spike glycoprotein from
from mers
and what they found is that in non-human
primates
uh the vaccination-induced high titers
of antibodies
and neutralizing antibodies against mers
covi
and that these non-human primates that i
didn't have space to show the data
but vaccination with this uh with this
plasmid containing the s gene
confer protection they then went on to
do uh phase one studies
and showed that uh in in healthy
individuals
that the the dna vaccine that that
expressed the s antigen for mers
was immunogenic and had very minor side
effects
um so this is really helpful because
this really shows us that this is it
could be a potential strategy
uh for uh for dna sorry for um
for a covet 19 vaccine and there's a
companies including inovio
which is actually pursuing this with a
um a dna vaccine of their own
against copen19 this is again another
another busy uh a busy table from uh
their their lancet paper
but it's just a highlight that they used
they tried they they tried different
dosages which is what you're usually
trying to do in a uh
a phase one study and they showed that
the the
there were very few adverse effects even
if you used a a
high dose of the um of the
uh of the vaccine and that's important
too because uh
it's not just immunogenicity if you have
a number of adverse effects not only is
that gonna
that has the potential to uh to harm the
individual who's
receiving the vaccine but it can also be
a bit of a challenge when you're trying
to roll out a
a large-scale uh vaccination program
okay let's move into some of the current
candidates uh that are
um on the market for uh or sorry uh
hoping to
to one day be on the market for uh for
covet 19.
um so as you remember as i showed at the
beginning there's
over 100 candidates so i obviously don't
have enough time uh to go through all of
them
so just highlighted a couple here that
have progressed into
uh into clinical trials so you see again
there's there's a spectrum of different
uh different vaccines that are that are
being investigated
including a subunit vaccine from using
the s protein from
novovax both canned signal biologics and
university of
oxford are using adenovirus vaccines uh
inovio that i alluded to is using a dna
vaccine and modernity which is uh
probably a lot of people have heard
about is using an rna-based vaccine that
encoding the s antigen
um so i think the uh the the thing
that's interesting is that uh
and and again really builds on the the
knowledge that we gain from stars and
merge is that
all the the vaccine candidates are using
the the engine just highlighting what a
what a promising
uh antigen it is um they uh the status
of these ones is uh
tends to differ it's uh it's unfortunate
there's not a lot of literature there's
not a lot of scientific literature
on um uh on the findings from the some
of the uh the pre-clinical work
and the uh the phase one study so
hopefully that will become available
soon
uh so that the the scientific community
can start evaluating these different
vaccines but we'll
we'll just have to wait and see so i'm
going to start with one of the ones
which is uh the most uh
uh furthest advanced so it's uh what's
called the uh
chad aux one which is uh uh stands for
the
chimp adeno virus uh from oxford
uh and this is the one that the this is
the the the chimp adenovirus that i that
that i
showed you in the previous table which
has been genetically modified
to uh express the uh the the s antigen
and again so it has moved past phase one
trial it's in it's in phase two and
three
uh and unfortunately i wasn't able to
find any um uh any published literature
on the phase one hopefully that'll be
soon
uh so instead i'm gonna present some of
the preclinical uh work that was done in
animals
um and i think it's quite promising but
again i should caution you that the data
i'm showing is from a pre-print so it
hasn't technically gone through
a formal scientific review
so uh what this uh what this group has
shown
is that uh when you uh when you
vaccinate either uh
mice or um uh or so what they did is
they they vaccinated mice and non-human
primates and they were looking for both
immunogenicity and actually in in
non-human primates they were gonna do
challenge studies
so for immunogenicity you're looking for
the trifecta you're looking for
virus-specific antibodies a nice high
titer uh
specifically neutralizing antibiotics as
well and virus-specific t
cells um for the challenge experiments
uh they they again they vaccinated the
the non-human primates and then they
challenged them with a relatively high
dose of uh
uh of sargo v2 so what you can see here
this is the uh this is their their
experimental design so the um
uh uh all the bars in red represent the
um
data from animals which is have received
the uh uh
the chimp adenovirus which has the
essence for for covet 19
and then the blue is the one uh these
are um from
animals that received uh chimp
adenovirus expressing the the gfp
protein so it's a green fluorescence
protein that's
not uh not from a virus um and it's
essentially it's the
it's your control group it's your sham
vaccine so
what they did is a uh um four weeks
before challenge they vaccinated their
animals
they uh they drew blood at um uh uh two
weeks later and then two weeks falling
to look at the immune response
then they did a challenge and uh
examined the animals up until day seven
when they did a necropolity to look at
um uh look at pathology and
and uh and viral load so from this what
you can see is we're
again we're getting the trifecta we're
getting in the the vaccinated animals
we're seeing a good
uh strong uh immune response or high
titers of
of both uh antibodies and specifically
viral
virus neutralizing antibodies and a good
good t cell response seen both in the
non-human primates
and in the bowel c mice that they used
um but obviously the question is
immune response is great but does it
actually confer protection
so again we're challenged by the fact
that this is a non-lethal model so
uh we don't know what the the the
animals don't don't die from this
disease so all that we can look at is
the viral burden and uh and the clinical
school and the clinical store
uh scores excuse me um what we saw is
that the
the vaccinated animals actually had uh
lower clinical scores suggesting a more
moderate disease
uh compared to their un uh their the
animals that received the uh the sham
vaccination
also in the uh in the sham vaccinated
group two out of three developed
pneumonia whereas in the vaccine group
uh none of the animals developed
pneumonia and then when they performed
necropsy
uh seven days after infection uh there
was lower viral loads in
the uh in the animals that received the
uh the
the chimp adenovirus that had the
expressing the s antigen
what was interesting though and i
unfortunately didn't have space to put
it in here but if
you look in the paper at day one and day
three they noticed that there was
no difference in the in the viral loads
for the for the nasal swab
um so this suggests that uh um
perhaps this vaccine while conferring
protection against severe disease
may not actually uh may not actually
confer protection against transmission
which is a bit disconcerting but
obviously we need further studies to
really uh to really investigate this
so overall i think that this vaccine uh
it looks incredibly promising um
at least based on the uh the animal data
they were able to confer protection in
non-human primate primates with only a
single dose of vaccine
and that's really important because you
know if you're going to roll something
out into into the general population
you ideally want a vaccine where you
won't have to have people come back
repeatedly
for multiple doses another appealing
aspect of this particular vaccine is
that
uh pre-existing immunity against the the
adenovirus is not likely because this is
a a shim pad no virus
with when you use human adenoviruses
there's always the concern of
pre-existing immunity which could limit
uh vaccine efficacy
um but this as i said a little bit less
of a less of a concern
um from looking on clinicaltrials.gov
they have completed a um
a a trial in over 500 adults
um and so hopefully we'll see that we'll
see the data soon on that
they've also struck the university of
oxford has also struck a partnership
with astrazeneca which will be useful
hopefully for production of the uh of
the vaccine
and uh right now face uh phase two slash
three trials underway
with a little bit of luck we may see
some some data by the by the end of the
year
so the next one i'm gonna talk about is
uh one that's completed phase
uh phase one trial recently so not as
far as uh
advanced as the uh the the chimp
adenovirus
um this is one uh by can sign on
biologics which is using uh an adeno5
vector which is
again expressing the uh the s antigen
from stars cov2
so in their um in their uh recently
completed phase one trial uh again the
uh just to highlight a little bit of
background so
adenophi uh antivirus five is a
it's a human adenovirus so if the people
uh
uh could get exposed to may have been
exposed to previously it causes a
respiratory infection so there is a
likelihood of pre-existing immunity in
in populations
um but so what they did is they this is
a um uh replication uh defective
adenovirus five that they
have um uh genetically modified to
express the uh that's
the s antigen from cyrus cov2 and this
was a dose escalation study
single center open label non-randomized
uh and they they had just under 200
volunteers who kind of
uh spanned a a whole age range
they did note that uh uh up to ten
percent or um
depending on the uh the group the the
vaccine group
uh more than ten percent of their
participants actually did have
pre-existing
uh pre-existing immunity to the um uh to
the adenovirus five
uh vector um but they did account for
that when they looked at the um
uh the immune response they did find
that their vaccine does
cause or sorry it does generate um a a
very robust immune response so good
good antibody titers and uh and good t
cell response
and they actually did break it down and
showed that even in the group that had
uh significant tight titers against the
against adenovirus 5
which you would suspect would make the
uh which would actually decrease the
the the immunogenicity of the vaccine
because your pre-existing immunity would
prevent your immune system from
potentially uh
taking in the um uh the virus they
actually saw that you you actually get
fairly robust response comparable
uh to the group that didn't uh didn't
have pre-existing immunity
which is encouraging but where we i
think have to pause a little bit
is um uh in in terms of uh when they
when they presented the um
uh the table showing the adverse effects
so i'll just draw your attention to
the fact that um over 75 percent of
participants in each category reported
uh
adverse effects and some of these
adverse effects could actually be pretty
serious so
fever pain headache uh fatigue
um and uh uh
um this is not it is not uncommon in a
lot of vaccine studies to see um
uh to have uh uh side effects pain
particularly
often at the site of injection but where
i think this is uh it could be
potentially problematic
is some of these adverse effects are
quite serious and you can imagine that
they they can things like fever and
fatigue can actually
mimic some of the symptoms you see with
covet 19 which
uh that in combination with uh with just
the um uh the high
likelihood of a participant having an
adverse effect this could be a problem
for
getting the population as a whole to
want to to want to take this uh
uh to want to sort of uptake this uh
this vaccine so it's something that we i
think we really need to consider
it's also important to remember that you
know previous vaccines using the adeno
5 antivirus 5 vector
have had have had problems such as the
well-known one in 2007 with the hiv
vaccine where they
actually showed that because of the the
pre-existing immunity or what they
believed to be pre-exist immunity
caused uh an increase in inflammation
which actually
uh increased the likelihood of virus at
uh acquisition
so what we don't know because this this
was the obviously safety and
tolerability uh or sorry safety and
dosage trial is we're not sure whether
pre-existing immunity to adenovirus 5
will exacerbate the disease in the
context of covet 19.
um and it's as i said the high the high
percentage of people who had adverse
effects is again a little disconcerting
because
when you compare it to the the recent
lancet id study that i uh spoke about
earlier using a dna vaccine against mers
uh sorry dnx vaccine for mers this was
also phase one study but showed that the
um uh individuals reported far fewer
adverse
adverse effects so perhaps it is
important to really find the right uh
the right vector for delivering your
antigen
so a lot of these questions we can't we
can't answer until we do further uh
further trials and further further
studies a phase two trial is underway so
all we can do is watch and hope that the
scientific community is looking into
some of these questions
so now i'll talk a little bit about a
canadian pre-clinical uh
vaccine candidate that i'm actually
fortunate to be uh to be
uh working on um so this is part of a
research consortium
amongst researchers at the university of
toronto uh sunnybrook health sciences
center
where i'm at and the universitai la
valle in quebec
and so what we're actually doing is
we're going to be comparing a number of
different
vaccine candidates including a dna
vaccine expressing the s antigen
virus-like particles and a protein
subunit vaccine
and we'll be determining which ones in
in pre-clinical studies
uh are are the most uh the most
efficacious we have
started some work we've done
immunogenicity studies uh starting with
the dna vaccine
uh that began in april uh and we're just
working on uh we're about to start our
our animal challenge experiments
to give you a little bit of background
so uh so dna vaccines um
are basically they're they're basically
circles of dna if anyone's ever worked
with a bacteria
you're probably very familiar with uh
with plasmids so
this is a um this is a commercial system
that you can order from from in vitrogen
but the idea is the same so um
one that we find is called a pidv which
is basically
a modified and improved version of the
pvax one we've done a number of
manipulations to it
uh in order to increase antigen
expression but
the the same there's a there's a the the
common the common theme for for dna
vaccines is basically what you have you
have this circle
of of dna and you get to insert your
favorite antigen here
uh in our case we've used the s antigen
from uh from stars cov2
uh and there's a selectable marker and
and a promoter system so that when this
vaccine is delivered into um into cells
it will it will express the antigen in
order to excite the uh
the immune system so uh we just recently
uh
completed the immunogenicity studies in
in uh
in bald c mice so this is data hot off
the uh the presses the hard work of uh
uh one of the post docs uh dr george uh
baby
uh has was kindly pro uh was able to
provide this data to me earlier this
week so
um uh it's looking quite promising uh
he's been investigating the
uh our dna vaccine uh with three
different uh three different versions of
the um the sarsko v2s antigen
um and he's shown in cell lines that
gets lots of uh we get really robust
antigen expression
and then in uh balb sea mice uh we're
able to generate
uh pretty significant titers of um
both um uh antibodies against uh
uh sarsko v2 as well as a robust a
robust t-cell response
so the next step is now that we've
showed these that this um vaccine is
immunogenic we'll be moving forward into
uh uh into actual vaccine challenge
studies
so stay tuned okay
so there's a couple of things that uh i
i think that we need to consider
for all vaccines moving forward and i
think these are not just challenges but
also potential
opportunities for the uh for the
scientific community
so one of the things that is uh that is
discussed and and and brought up quite
frequently is this idea of antibody
dependent enhancement
so if you look at the um uh the figure
just to the side of uh
of your screen right here under ideal
circumstances if you have antibodies
against a virus so let's say for
again stars cov2 the antibodies will
bind to the virus
and neutralize it in order to prevent
the virus from uh
binding to the receptor and entering the
cells and that's that's what we're
hoping for with a with a good
a good vaccine now the concern is
something called antibody dependent
enhancement
whereby the uh antibody will not
uh will not bind uh quite correctly but
will
um bind to the the um
sorry the fcr receptor will uh will bind
to the cell and then facilitate virus
uptake
um or the
the other one which is immune mediated
enhancement which is kind of like a
different flavor of antibody dependent
enhancement whereby the antibodies
actually
uh cause um not only virus uptake but
also
uh the generation of a a
pro-inflammatory immune response
um and this is uh so this this concept
of ad is is actually quite familiar for
a lot of other viruses including
there have been reports of it for uh for
influenza um
but uh probably the most well known is
actually with with a dengue virus and we
saw this with um
this was a concern with the uh the
dengue vaccine
two years ago but in terms for
coronaviruses
this phenomenon has been observed uh
when we do in vitro
studies so antibodies against the s
protein have been shown to in
enhanced coronavirus uptake different
for different coronavirus
um species not just um uh not just sars
at least in in cell culture um and also
when people have done this uh have done
these sorts of studies using
animals again they they have noticed
what they
uh this this sort of increase in in
pathology so
this is a recent paper from published
just uh uh just back in in 2019 in
uh in jci um so what was done is um
uh rhesus mccox were were vaccinated
either with the uh
vaccinia virus expressing the um uh
the the s antigen from the the from
first stars from stars cov1 or they were
just given uh
vaccinia virus so that was the the
control uh the control vector
um and when these animals were were uh
were vaccinated then subsequently
challenged with sarge one
uh and then uh necropsied after after
infection
uh they reported that the vaccinated
animals actually had
a greater lung histopathology uh
compared to the
animals that had received the the
vaccine that didn't have the s antigen
and they also did studies where they
said well if we give antibodies uh
that are specific for this uh for the um
for the s antigen we give it to animals
what do we see
uh in in terms of uh pathology following
an infection
and again higher histopathology scores
indicating
there's more inflammation and more
pathology in the uh
in the lungs so i should i should
highlight this was done with uh with
stars one
not with uh not with sars ko v2 um
but i think the uh uh so that's uh so
that is quite compelling data and it's
it's certainly um
uh it's certainly interesting and worthy
of uh of of further studies
but what's interesting is when you when
you go through the some of the fine
details of the of this paper
they did do radiography uh so they did
like like a chest x-ray
uh on the animals um throughout the
course of the study
but uh they didn't report whether or not
the the radiography was worse than the
uh in the vaccinated
or so the animals that received the um
the sars-kobe vaccine compared to the
ones that received the uh
the the sham vaccine or if it was just
even worse than
than animals that were unvaccinated and
were just infected with uh
with with sarsko v1 which they didn't uh
was not a group that was
included as part of their study they
also didn't comment on whether the
clinical signs and symptoms were
actually worse so
did did one group of of animals have
more left energy more shortness of
breath decreased appetite which are all
things that are easy to measure
uh when you're when you're doing an
animal study with with
non-human primates so other than the
histopathology
they didn't present any evidence showing
that uh the non-human primates
actually did uh did worse in the end so
it really makes you wonder the animals
even noticed that they had this
uh what this uh antibody dependent
enhancement the only way we can know
that for certain is
whether we have we we actually have to
do these studies uh
in in non-human primates obviously with
our vaccines against covid19
and we need to do longer uh longer
follow-up study so we need to
once the animals recover we'll need to
need to follow them and and
and really examine to make sure that
there there isn't um
there isn't any uh additional pathology
it may even require
a subsequent second challenge just to
make sure that this
uh to determine whether or not there
isn't any antibody
dependent enhancement these are all very
important things to determine that we
we want to know this before we start uh
licensing and approving vaccines we
want to make sure but there aren't any
unintended uh unintended side effects
and i think this is this is a great
opportunity for the scientific community
to investigate this and answer some of
these questions
so other things that we need to consider
is obviously uh if if we have a
promising candidate
we'll need to uh we'll need to scale up
production um so we'll need to be able
to develop
many many uh doses of the vaccine uh in
order to to vaccinate a
subsequent or a large enough um
component of the the population in order
to confer
immunity so it's actually quite
encouraging that there are so many
candidates in fact
i if you ask me i'm hoping that there
isn't just one vaccine that works i'm
hoping there's
you know three or four or half a dozen
because this will really alleviate a lot
of the production
uh problems if you have six vaccines
that are all working equally well
then that's six different companies that
can be producing it in six different
sites or in six different places
you know and this will really help uh
help get the um
get the the population vaccination level
up faster
um we also need to understand a little
bit uh
whether or not we can develop a vaccine
which will uh not just protect against
severe disease but um
but may also protect against against
transmission as it showed some of the
preliminary data from the uh
the chimp adeno uh uh vaccine uh
it's suggesting that maybe it doesn't
prevent against transmission but the
only way to know that is with them
with good solid uh animal studies and of
course doing doing follow-up studies
during your
um uh your various phases of clinical
trials
also we need to figure out now what
level of protection are we willing to
tolerate
so it would be ideal if we had a vaccine
that was 100 percent
effective and uh and and protects people
i don't think anyone would argue with
that
but when it comes to deciding are are we
going to
be able to uh use a vaccine that's
that's only 60 percent protective
probably but what if our what if our top
candidate's only 40 percent protective
so these are all important questions
that that we need to we need to consider
now and of course
deter and once we know that level of
protection that will also help us
develop what
what would be the optimal vaccination
strategy it's unlikely that we're going
to be able to
uh generate billions of doses very
quickly so we'll have to determine
uh i i don't know how feasible would be
to vaccinate 5 billion people i
i don't i don't make vaccines for a
living but uh even if with uh with
optimal uh
uh production levels and some companies
are saying they will be able to produce
millions if not billions of doses we may
have to determine what will be the the
priority population so
potentially uh you know the elderly the
immunocompromised healthcare providers
a vaccine strategy needs to be developed
in advance so that once we have that
ready to go that we're
uh that we don't we don't lose any time
so i i'm i'm a a glass is half full kind
of guy uh so i'm
i i hope that i've sort of conveyed a
note of optimism but
i think to to summarize i think there's
there's five reasons that i'm i'm very
optimistic that we're going to have a
a really good vaccine against covet 19.
the first one being
we are only five months after
identifying this uh this virus i know it
seems like it's
you know it seems like it's it's three
or four times that it's been five months
since we identified stars cov2 and
already we have more than 100 candidates
that are in
uh either pre-clinical or uh or various
stages of clinical uh
trials so that is incredibly encouraging
we've got all the tools that we need to
do a lot of these studies we've got good
animal models we've got the virus
isolated we've got what we need to
really
uh really push things forward we've also
saved a lot of time and learned a lot i
think
from lessons from from sars and mers and
i think that's why we are
so far uh so far ahead compared to how
we would be had we
not learned anything from stars and mers
we have
multiple candidates moving forward which
again i think is really important
because
then we don't have reliance on a single
winner in fact as i
keep going back to my my hope is that we
by the end of the year we have maybe
you know four or five candidates that
are either about to be licensed or or in
phase three
uh for phase three trials and i think
that that uh
seeing the speed that uh uh and the the
sort of
you know the will of the of the
scientific and medical communities i
think that there is an excellent chance
that we will see some phase three
clinical
uh trial data by the end of the year
so with that uh i'd just like to thank
some of my colleagues who uh
who've been involved in in our own
little uh our own little piece of
the the vaccine development for our our
um
our vaccine consortium so that's my
colleagues here at uh landbrook health
sciences center dr samir mubaraka
and uh and and her lab and my colleagues
at the university te la val dr gary
coppinger
uh dr george uh babawadzi who has been
just instrumental in in
in in pushing a lot of us forward and uh
and dr gary wong
and with that i would be uh more than
happy to uh to take any questions
and thank you dr kozak for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and questions submitted today and during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via contact information
you provided the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through the end of the year 2020. lab
routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share
this email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time take care bye